Okay, hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. And we are live on holistic health hour, our 24th or so episode
where we answer your questions or at least I try the best to do so.
Remember to ask your questions prior to if you want to on holistichealthhour.com
holistichealthhour.com is where you can see a question box where you could answer, ask any questions that you want.
And I'll do my best to answer them if it's not appropriate. Of course, we want to address that.
We have a number of questions that came in. So let's jump to those. Remember you could ask them live on the chat here too.
So chat in your questions. Hopefully it will receive those while you're watching this.
So you don't have to go that much site right now. But you can also see all our older episodes on holistichealthhour.com
where we have them laid out. We don't really nice as far as topically where you could find anything specific you want.
And a reminder to go to cuttersclinics.io.ed.
ersclinic.com where you'll see well over a thousand blog posts that are well indexed.
So you could just search in the search bar for anything that you're specifically looking for.
Pretty good chance that I made a video about it or at least written a blog post about it and you could find it in there.
Okay, first question that came in. I've been taking two capsules of phase two colon support.
And for those that don't know phase two colon support has some triophia triophia in it.
But the biggest thing in it, that's to help heal the colon has magnesium in it for bowel movements aid.
And then it has some cape allo in it. For those who are not familiar with cape allo cape allo is a great supplement. Don't confuse it with allo.
Allo products that are healing to the gut or allo products that are immune stimulators for allo products that are cancer fighters that cape allo is a type of product that will help you with bowel movements.
So this has also cape allo in it, hence the phase six colon support phase six has to do with your moving your bowel.
So phase six refers to the detoxification pathway. And this product is actually one of our private table product. That's why we use the phase six out there.
So phase six, if you're not familiar with our seven phases of detoxification phase six is the phase of detoxification where you're getting it's destroyed, right.
So phase six colon support has 50 milligrams of the cape allo in it. Now, honestly, and I think that's per I think that's for two capsules too. So honestly, that's not very much cape allo.
We have another product. I think it's called phase six assist and that has 250 milligrams of cape allo. So the difference there, right.
So if a person is really constipated and having issues, we typically recommend that phase six assist, which has a much higher amount of cape allo. It's not really anything else but the cape allo.
But that is really going to help a person move their balls. But let me get to this person's question. I've been taking two capsules in the phase six colon support every night at bedtime for almost two weeks. I'm not quite as constipated though.
The DMs have are more frequent than in the last few days that have increased in size a bit that are still not back to normal. Should I give it more time or increase the dosage my water take is 70 to 90 ounces a day.
So no, there's so when a person has constipation issues, maybe their first go to should be should be magnesium.
So that's what people are most familiar with. So you take excess magnesium. You can't really take too much magnesium because you'll just dump that magnesium in the ball. But what that will do is it'll draw water to the ball and it will typically loosen up your stools.
So taking way too much magnesium is good. You're going to really do the stool. So you've got to watch that. It doesn't always work with everybody.
So then using something like Cape Aloe can be your next best bet. So taking Cape Aloe can help get you regulated. Again, this particular product, the basics colon support is a much lower dose of Cape Aloe.
So I would just up the dosage tell you feel like you're more regular and then you could lower the dosage down.
Again, for people who have really bad constipation issues or just have once in a while, they have bad constipation issues using the phase six assist, which is the higher or dosage of Cape Aloe.
And just doing that once in a while can be a better choice. The basics colon support is more for long term use. It can be healing to the colon as well.
And it's not so much about mover as it is as is the other that was the higher dose of Cape Aloe.
Question came in. I take magnesium glycinate to per day should I take magnesium citrate. So typically you'll read out there that there's better forms of magnesium for for ball movement support helping with constipation.
And that is true because there are certain forms of magnesium that will tend to be absorbed less readily.
So magnesium citrate is probably the best form of magnesium if you're just taking it.
And then you get it wholly to move your bowels because it's the most poorly absorbable magnesium.
So you'll keep more of it in the colon and that's the whole idea that you'll draw more water and it'll help with your vowels. Now understand magnesium won't work with a person that is dehydrated or semi dehydrated.
So you're drinking a lot of water. So you need to have enough water for your bowels to pull draw water from the magnesium that's in there. So.
Okay, so thank you. I think I wanted to run phase six. So I this phase six colon support is actually a really good product to help to just gently move your bowels and to help heal your gut.
It's a great time. But the phase six assist would be solely just for bowel movement support and would be used more intermittently.
Now we have some patients that take phase six assist all the time or they just have a history of constipation.
We have some people that contact us and they say, I'm not constipated. I have a bowel movement every three days.
But at least one good bowel movement every day. You're constipated in my book. So you have to be moving your balls. If you're not getting out what's on the inside, you're getting just more and more toxic and that's not helpful for anymore.
Next question. Dear Dr. Cutters, the gastro doctor has recommended for my 71 year old husband to have endoscopy.
What would the risk be for such a test and also are there risks and possible solutions to counteract any possible sedation given?
So there's risks with most tests, right? So again, you have to look at any test that you do. You have to look at is the reward outweigh the risk.
So why would a person do an endoscopy? They're having upper GI symptoms. So they're having possible issues is suspected that the person may have a space occupied lesion in the esophagus, in the stomach, in the duodenum, the first part of the small intestine.
If they're if it's suspect that they have an ulcer formation. So there's different reasons why this person should get the test.
There's that's a great test to be able to visualize different things they can take biopsy during the test of tissue that looks suspect it's a good test to do if the person's having problems.
Are there negatives? Well, there's any there's there's negatives to every test, but so is there negatives to having to use sedation? Well, sure, you could have sensitivity to sense to sedation medication.
And like any medication, you have to detoxify that medication afterwards. So what would you do to help with that? You just support the liver detox pathways post treatment.
You wouldn't necessarily increase liver detoxification support prior to treatment because you wouldn't want to have to require more sedation if you have more active phase two phase one, two, three pathways in the liver.
So I'd say after the the procedure that you could support phase one, two, three, well, it's just support all your detoxification pathways really.
So it's just like when people ask me, okay, should I do a CT scan? You know, we have cancer patients. Should I do a CT scan? Should I do a PET scan? What's the pros and cons to that?
Well, you do it to satisfy the need for, you know, to find out what's going on to get a better diagnostic picture.
And I always recommend with any invasive test. So it's, well, CT scans are not invasive. They don't kind of be open. Well, it's invasive because you're getting radiation exposure.
Same with PET scan, same, you know, people cancer patients may be concerned with the glucose solution that you have to consume prior to the PET scan.
And MRI is less invasive, isn't it? Well, usually it's with a contrast die. So usually you are exposed to Galileo. So there's issues with that. So there's invasiveness with any test that you have.
So you have to weigh out that level of invasive this, the dangers that that is going to happen to the benefits of the test.
And I always recommend that you only run a test to if it's going to change the way you treat the patient.
So you know, it's not always beneficial to run just run a PET scan just to see, you know, are you doing better?
Unless it's going to change the way I treat the patient or the patient's perspective, you do a test if it's going to change the way you're going to choose whatever treatment plan depending upon what comes out of that test.
So yes, should you do a CT scan on a patient who has a history of cancer, if I don't know if they're spread of the cancer? Well, if it's going to change the way you as the patient are going to then approach treatment, then yes, I would agree to that test.
Meaning that if it comes back where I am, maybe the test is to bold, let's say, are you going to treat it differently?
If the answer is yes, then maybe you should go ahead with that test. If the answer is no, I'm not going to do anything different. I'm going to keep doing everything that I'm doing right now. Well, then why are you going to, you know, put yourself in a position where you could have negative effects from the procedure itself.
So those are the things that you decisions that you make in as a doctor in suggesting the test and decisions you make as a patient, whether you should agree to a test.
Is it going to change the way I treat myself?
So in the case of an endoscopy, if the doctor saying I really feel like he could have this, that you could have it also, so I'd like to go and look at that.
Is it going to change the way you treat it? Well, to get a diagnostic picture, maybe it will. Maybe it won't. Maybe you're going to say, no, I'm just going to treat it with natural methods and such anyhow, well, then maybe you should just go that route first and maybe if your symptoms clear up and other tests that are less important.
Test that are less invasive like blood work clears up that you don't decide to move forward with that. So those are the decision making processes that you have to make when you're doing any type of invasive testing.
Next question. I had a thyroid cancer and I assume I had Hashimoto's before that.
I've been hypothyroid for many years and I had surgery last year to remove the nodules and my thyroid. Since they were large, I also had radiation.
I've had stomach issues most of my life. So several years ago, I went plant based, which helped.
And now it seems that I might have been related to my thyroid. Since my surgery my endocrinologist is also put me out of gluten free diet. Now that I am no longer, now that I no longer have a thyroid, how can I care for my body to avoid other autoimmune responses.
I wish I had seen this website years ago.
Okay, so that's unpacked this question. I had thyroid cancer. This person had their thyroid removed. They assume that Hashimoto's before that.
So you can still do it even though you have no thyroid gland. You had it surgically removed. You can still test for thyroid antibodies.
So if you had your thyroid removed and you're then unsyntheroid because you have no thyroid, you're not producing it.
Thyroid hormone. You still should be running thyroid a thyroid panel to make sure that you're in normal levels of T3 and T4.
In that thyroid panel, you should be requested, you know, a full thyroid panel. So not just TSH, T3 and T4, but you should be requesting reverse T3 and you should be requesting TPO antibodies of thyroid gland and pantybodies.
So those two antibodies, TPO antibodies, the thyroid gland antibodies are going to test whether you have Hashimoto's first and still can have Hashimoto's even though they have thyroid.
And that definition of that is that you have antibodies to those thyroid tissue.
And that's not going to cause issues when I don't have a thyroid anymore. That one's going to cause less issues. You're not going to have to worry about damage to the thyroid since that existed anymore, but at least you'll know whether you had those antibodies.
Many times even though you don't have a thyroid gland anymore, you'll still have show presence of those antibodies.
Secondly, you can test for other tissue antibodies, a Syrex array five and a Syrex array seven X tests for specific tissue antibodies.
You could also request an antibody test from your medical doctor, give it your history. I would think that they would be open to ordering those tests.
You could test for systemic antibodies and antibodies, other systemic antibodies.
There's a patient, their doctor ran a whole bunch of antibody tests for them who's covered under their insurance.
So I think it's wise to request those tests and get those tests run.
Down to this person's question, I've had stomach problems my whole life. I've been on play based in my sense my surgery, my endocrinologist told me to go on a gluten-free diet.
Well, it hats off to your endocrinologist. I tell you right now, because that's an endocrinologist who's reading some literature.
So why would someone recommend a gluten-free diet with somebody with thyroid issues?
And the reason is, anybody with thyroid issues whether it's primary hypothyroidism, which you were diagnosed with, which you assumed that they never tested for Hashimoto.
Primary hypothyroidism is that this person is showing a combination of elevated TSH, low T3, low T4, some combination thereof.
But no antibodies, their TPO antibodies are negative, that they're a globular antibodies are negative.
That would be a diagnosis of primary hypothyroidism. That means you have low thyroid, but you don't have Hashimoto's.
If you have one of those antibodies elevated, that means you fall into the category of Hashimoto's.
So, if you have any thyroid issues, primary hypothyroidism, Hashimoto's, or Graves' disease, which is hyperthyroid, you should not be gluten.
You don't want to, nobody, you don't need to do a gluten test. It has nothing to do with gluten sensitivity.
It doesn't have to do it with having gliated antibodies.
The reason is that gliated is a molecular mimic to the thyroid.
So, it's not pertaining to having sensitivities to gluten.
It's pertaining to the fact that just from a molecular structure, gliated is a molecular mimic.
There are certain things that we can consume that could be molecular mimics to self-tissue.
Well, gliated is a molecular mimic to the thyroid.
Every time you eat gluten, you're going to, you have the ability to stimulate an immune reaction on the thyroid planet.
So, even if a person is primary hypothyroidism, and they are eating gluten, they can end up with Hashimoto's and develop antibodies to the thyroid.
So, everybody with gluten with thyroid issues, even with thyroid cancer, should not be eating gluten.
Now, I'll longer have a thyroid. How can I care for my body to avoid other autoimmune responses?
And the answer is, you want to, in order to avoid developing antibodies to self-tissue, you want to avoid stimulating these immune system spikes.
So, when we have immune system spikes, then that gives us a greater ability to develop antibodies to self-tissue.
So, boy, that's hard. How do you get immune system spikes?
You get immune system spikes from having a damage you've got, and developing antibodies to other foods.
So, you can have food sensitivities, and every time you eat that food, you create an immune system spike.
Every time you create an immune system spike, you create the ability to develop antibodies to other things.
Toxins in our environment can create immune system spikes, you know, poisons that we're exposed to by breathing and consuming, and dies in food color, and et cetera, et cetera.
So, damage should have got antibodies to food, immune system spikes from toxins are your biggest reasons why you would develop, and biotoxins as well.
Another biggest reason is why you develop cell antibodies or develop an autoimmune disease.
So, trying to live a clean life, basically trying to eat organic, trying to, you know, clean up my diet, maybe wise, to run a Syrex array 10.
So, if you want, if you think you have an autoimmune disease, then you can run the Syrex self-antibody propiles, which would be the array 5 and the array 7x.
If you think, well, I don't think I have an autoimmune disease, I'm just trying to prevent it, then running Syrex array 10 food sensitivity panel to see,
wow, am I setting myself up for a possible immune response, these immune fluctuations that could set up a possible autoimmune disease.
So, Syrex array 10 from a practical standpoint to really diminish and start realizing what I need to do to start healing my gut.
Next question.
I have, I have an enlarged heart. How do I reduce the size naturally? Right now, my doctor, my doctor's had me on blood pressure meds.
Well, typically you won't go on blood pressure meds just because you have an enlarged heart. You go on blood pressure meds because you either have high blood pressure.
Or you have a regular beats. So, if you have a regular irregularity of your heart due to an enlarged heart, then you might be a beta blockers type of which is a blood pressure med, but that's typically what you use if you had an enlarged heart.
If you have a high blood pressure without anything else, then typically you'll go on like an ACE2 inhibitor, which would be like an acid form or something like that.
Can you reduce your enlarged heart naturally? No, you can't reduce your enlarged heart naturally.
Having an enlarged heart is common. It's common with athletes. I have an enlarged heart because I ran track across country at high school, probably.
The danger of an enlarged heart is that as your heart is growing and the muscle tissue is expanding, it can cause your valves to maybe not shut as thoroughly.
And you can get valveular issues where you get some regurgitation in the ventricles. So, I mean, that is a possibility.
Also, with an enlarged heart, you can get some issues with the side of atrial node and you can get issues with irregular beats.
None of those are really dangerous except the valveular issue if you're end up getting valveular infections.
Typically, treating with using garlic in your diet, unless you have an autoimmune disease, you don't have an autoimmune disease using garlic on a regular basis.
Probably the best thing for any infections on the valves and infections in the blood system in general.
Garlic is one of the best solutions for that. But no, there isn't really anything from a natural perspective for that.
If a person has irregularities or tachycardia issues, also you want to look at vitamin D from a tachycardia perspective.
Over the years, I've had patients that had different times where they go into a particular tachycardia.
And it was from a vitamin D deficiency. I had one patient once, this was years ago, whose mother was in the particular tachycardia.
They were going to use the shock pads under which they don't like to do on anybody that is alive because that could kill them or anybody that is awake because they could be very dangerous.
All we did is, all she did is give her mom 20,000 I use a vitamin D and it called your heart out. She didn't have to have it without your sore.
So that can be an issue. So getting your vitamin D levels checked in your blood would be wise. We've had people get the right of a D levels checked and it's like 15.
So a person even taking vitamin D can have low vitamin D levels because you can have vitamin D receptor defects on your genes so you don't absorb vitamin D very well.
You know, utilize it very well if you need to take a lot more than what you're taking.
So those are some things to consider for.
Next question. My child is showing signs of allergies now that it's close to summer. What do you recommend?
So I recommend typically something having seasonal allergies like the pollen that I just cut the grass today and I bumped into one of our white pine bridge branches of the white pine tree.
And the pollen that came off in there is like, oh my goodness, I wish I were at a video and it was just amazing.
Seasonal allergies are an issue taking the natural antihistamines. We use our clear hiss junior for kids, which is fantastic because it's delicious and it's doable and it tastes like candy.
So you make sure you keep it covered where the kids can attack it because it tastes kind of like sweethearts.
But clear hiss junior is one of the best ones I think for kids because they'll take it.
And that has, of course, it's in some of the natural antihistamines type things.
For adults, we have a natural clear hiss, which is similar to that.
We also have our clear histamine scavenger, which is a little bit different.
So with adults and with kids, you have to kind of experiment with what nutrients are going to be the best for reducing histamine.
The clear histamine scavenger has a lot more in it that will support all the pathways.
And we always just think of histamine, but there's, oh my goodness, there's a rat food at the feeder.
Thank you.
All right.
Live, cutters, but a climb.
We have a rat food at my bird feeder.
So clear histamine scavenger is one of my favorite because it supports more pathways.
than just the histamine pathways.
So you have these inflammatory cytokines that are flared when you're exposed to things that are foreign to the body.
So the purpose of these inflammatory cytokines is to stimulate an immune reaction.
If it's something that the body can kill, so what can the body kill?
So bacteria, you know, fungi, viruses, can the body kill pollen?
No.
So then you have another genetic system that stimulates this anti-histamine type reaction, which gets rid of histamine in all these other cytokines and combs that all down.
Well, that gene pathway, the HMT pathway, it's not uncommon to have defects.
Genetic defects in that pathway.
So it reduces one's ability to get rid of tissue, histamines, and inflammatory cytokines in tissues, but it happens.
So that is why, you know, why do some people, you know, have allergic reactions to pollen and other people that's bothering them at all?
Why do some people, you know, have seasonal allergies and other people's don't?
Well, there's can be other reasons.
So it can be histamine overload, it can be inflammation overload, so that's a good thing to explore with your child as well.
Do they have food sensitivity?
So they already produce a lot of inflammatory cytokines and they get reaction to pollen down.
So, okay, is it that? Is it just overload of inflammation?
Do they have inflammation going on because, you know, dies in their foods that they're eating because they ate a bag of skittles?
And they have food sensitivities because they're gluten and dairy.
And they're exposed to pollen, and now it just tips them over basically, so they have this inflammation that, you know, you're going to the doctor and taking over the color antihistamines and such like that.
We're even taking natural antihistamines.
So you're going to look at these things, digging to the reason why.
So, many times people think, oh, I just have allergies.
Well, yeah, you do have allergies. Maybe you have, you know, defects in your H&M teaching, so you don't get rid of histamine very well, that could be possible.
But maybe you wouldn't be tipping over if you dealt with the food sensitivities, if you dealt with the reaction to dies and chemicals and glyphosate that you're consuming or being exposed to as well.
So, it is kind of like a bucket effect.
So, the more things that you throw into the bucket, it's going to overflow.
So, the more things you can empty out of the bucket, it can reduce your reaction to things that you thought you were, quote, unquote allergic to, like pollens that are environment.
So, look at that as well, but as far as products, those would be the products that I'd recommend.
Next question, why is RIF technology not more widely known and accepted?
So, RIF technology, for those who maybe listening to us and that have no familiarity with who we are, you should go to our website, cuttersclinic.com.
That's a big piece of what we do is using RIF frequency technology to help people with all sorts of things, but live and cancer and things like that.
It's most beneficial for. So, RIF technology is using frequencies to help your body heal.
Why is it not widely known and why are doctors recommending it? Well, that's a good question.
Well, partly because insurance doesn't pay for it. That's a big piece. Sorry, but it's just the world that we live in.
Insurance is not paid for RIF technology and so you're going to have to go to somebody who's using this kind of off label, you could say.
Secondly, there's a lot of doctors that are licensed in practice that are afraid to use it because they're afraid that they're medical or car practice or cancer opathy boards are going to come after them and they're going to get in trouble.
There's a lot of truth to them. So, that's one of the reasons why we are licensed clinic anymore.
We don't treat equal equal patients anymore. We're only making recommendations and care for people to make their own decisions.
So, that's a big part of it. And then lastly, it's just another thing to learn.
It's like, you know, we get the question, why don't all doctors understand autoimmune diseases? I took your course and you really give a good explanation of different things.
Why are all doctors understanding this? Well, because it takes a long time to study this stuff.
And, you know, a lot of doctors are just trying to make it and they don't have time or the desire to spend thousands of dollars and thousands of hours to learn something that they don't even know how to market that.
So, it's, yeah, it's difficult. So, that's just the world that we live in.
And I don't think it's getting better. I've had patients years ago say, I just think life's going to be standard of care and it's going to be in Mayo pretty soon.
And this is just going to be so fantastic. I just don't, I just never agreed with them and I still don't agree with them.
It's just our pharmaceutical industry is basically controlling the media, it's controlling everything, probably after I said all that, this video.
So, let's move on. Next, my daughter, it was diagnosed with low thyroid, but the only test the doctor did was a TSH.
She put her scintoride, is that okay? I mean, I don't know this person's history or anything like that, but no, that's not okay.
If that is true, that's like the practice in my book. You don't diagnose low thyroid on elevated TSH.
So, TSH is thyroid stimulated hormone, it's secreted by the pituitary gland to tell the thyroid to screen more thyroid hormone.
So, when the blood levels of T3 and T4 are low, it stimulates the hypothalamus to tell the pituitary to tell the thyroid to screen more T4.
Most of the hormones created by the thyroid that is T4, there's just about 5% is T3, T3 is the active four.
And then T4 has to be converted to T3 in the liver, in the gut, and that conversion can be an issue right there.
So, it can be converted inadvertently to what's called reverse T3. And that can be the person's problem.
So, to investigate the thyroid thoroughly, you want to run total T3 and T4, three T3 and T4, and then a TSH and then a reverse T3 to see if T4 is getting converted to a bad form of T3, which is not active.
It is not beneficial and will never re-convert to active T3.
And then, you should run thyroid glomulin antibodies and TPO antibodies, so we discussed with that other patient's question before.
Because you have to know whether you're dealing with Hashimoto's or not.
So, just running TSH is not adequate, and it's not adequate to use TSH as you're so marker for use to eat a medication, I think that's just wrong.
It's just bad doctrine.
You have to look at T3 and T4 levels. TSH, actually, if you're in your TSH level, let's say every hour for a day you'd have different levels of TSH.
You can't use that as you're being marker.
Next question, what is a good time to get thermography, and is it a viable substitute for a mammography?
So, mammographies are obviously x-rays of your breasts to diagnose any irregularities and lesions that then would require getting a biopsy and to test for possible cancer.
Thermography is a heat-sensitive instrument. So, is thermography a viable substitute for mammography, in my opinion, yes.
But they are testing different things. So, you're going to see different things in an x-ray of the breast versus thermography of the breast.
I think thermography is best used for screening. Thermography is not a diagnostic tool. So, you can't use it for diagnostic, nor can you really use mammography for diagnostic in the case of cancer.
So, the only way to diagnose cancer is with a biopsy.
Thermography is going to be much more sensitive to the mammography. You're going to catch things earlier, and that's been the biggest complaint in the medical field with thermography.
You're diagnosing things too early. First of all, incorrect. Thermography is a diagnosing, but it is giving you an idea that there's something wrong.
So, if you have a regular thermography, which I think you're getting annual thermographies, if everything is clean up with thermography, thermographies are read by radiologists, medical radiologists.
So, it's not something that should even be considered alternative. So, I am not a fan of annual mammographies, that radiation that you're putting your breast on an annual basis could be cancer-causing to itself.
There's no negatives of a thermography. It's taking a thermal picture. So, there's zero in base on a thermography. So, it's really a perfect screening tool.
So, but it is just a screening tool. So, you use that and, oh, let's say something is positive on there, then maybe you'll check that more regularly. Maybe you'll run two marker tests. Maybe you'll go to get an ultrasound done.
It will pinpoint different things that maybe you want to look at and move forward with. So, what is a good time to do a thermography? When you're healthy, it's a really good time to get it doing a thermography.
Should everybody be doing a thermography? Yes, everybody should be doing a thermography. Every moment should be doing a thermography, for sure.
It's a thermography, this isn't a question, but is thermography misused? Well, I think any test can be misused. I had a male once committed to, I had prostate cancer, but I had a thermography that didn't show up. It's not going to show up on thermography.
So, the thermography is going to show more surface things. I know, you know, a license in thermography certified, but it doesn't mean I necessarily agree that you're going to be able to see abdominal issues clearly with thermography. There's better tests to use.
Thermography is great for surface things. Thermography can be helpful for therapy. Thermography can be helpful for a lot of things, but just like any test, like any blood test, anything else, a test is to give you clues as a diagnostician, to give you clues.
Say, oh, well, there's something going on here. We need to dig a little bit deeper. We need to correlate that with other objective and subjective findings and subjective and objective tests in order to move forward with our working diagnosis.
So, part of being a good clinician is you're doing what's called differential diagnosis to come to a conclusion to a working diagnosis. And they'll say in medicine that you come to a final diagnosis, but in truth, in practice, everything is a working diagnosis.
So, that's what you use thermography and blood tests and CTs and MRIs and everything to give you a working diagnosis to decide how you're going to move forward in a treatment plan.
And then what you do through that treatment plan is you retest to make sure that you've actually accomplished something in through that working diagnosis.
So, this is what I see as a failure in our medical field today. So often do I talk to people that had blood tests done, they had abnormalities on that blood test.
It's like, what did your doctor do? Nothing. He didn't even talk to me about it.
Okay, you have anemia on this blood test that you had last September. He never did another blood test. I mean, this is just criminal.
So, he never even told the person that they had anemia in order to even start a treatment procedure. Why do you do the blood tests in the first place?
If you're not using that test to move towards a working diagnosis or give you clues that you should do other diagnostic procedures in order to help the patient.
And then when you make the clinical decision to help the patient, then you rerun the tests that gave you that indication of what was abnormal is to see if you've actually collected it.
I think this is pretty cold and sensical, but it seems like we've lost cold and sensed in this country a lot of happening. So, that's my take.
Can you recommend a supplement or diet program to ward off dementia? My mother died with it and I want to prevent it.
There is a really good test that came out a couple of years ago. It's through Syrex Labs. It's called Alzheimer's Leaks.
That's a really good test, but even if you ran that test and everything was normal on that test, there's things that we should all do for a preventative standpoint for dementia.
So, if I don't have, let's say, any major symptoms of dementia and I don't really want to spend the money on that test, what are some things?
Maybe this is a question that the person asked me, what are some things that a person could do to ward off dementia?
Number one, you do things to decrease inflammation because inflammation that got equals inflammation of the brain.
So, if you are eating foods that is causing a inflammatory response to the gut, you're going to cause inflammation of the brain, especially with gluten or dairy.
You have gluteal morphine, in case you have morphine receptors of the gut that fire inflammatory receptors of the brain and you're going to cause inflammation of the brain.
Any inflammation of the brain is going to lead to issues. So, especially when you have excess inflammation, it's going to lead to issues.
One could cause inflammation of the brain, like I said, problems with the gut. Secondly, post-concussive issues.
Even if you've had, you know, never ever getting knocked out if you've gotten hit in the head, you put it all as a kid, you played sports as a kid, you played soccer, then the worst.
Heady, the ball, the soccer. You know, you've had falls slipping, pulling your head on different things.
Even a dozen, two dozen years ago, can cause inflammatory issues in the brain that are long-standing.
I have a video, if you go to cuttersplinic.com, you search neuroinflammation.
I have a front half hour video on neuroinflammation and microglial primate because the microglial cells are responsible for scavenging of bad guys in the brain and are for helping decrease inflammatory cytokites in the brain.
So, looking at that would be highly beneficial. It's a half hour of your life, but it could save you from early dementia issues.
So, a, the thing you want to do for dementia is decrease inflammation. Like I said, got issues caused inflammation of the brain.
Post-concussive syndrome, even dozens of years ago, caused inflammation of the brain and microglial primate.
I'm going to say at these little things that they inject in your arm that have adjuvings, need to have adjuvings.
They don't work without adjuvings. Adjuvings are other chemicals that they have to add to that solution that they inject in your arm.
Those adjuvings cross the blood-brain barrier and damage the blood-brain barrier.
Blood-brain barriers is basically your another type of glial cell, your astrocytes that wrap around the blood vessels of the brain and they can become damaged by chemicals and those chemicals can be damaged.
It is said that, oh, the little bit of mercury or the little bit of aluminum that's if these fluke shots are, is, is a nano-illumative.
So, it's, it's hardly noticeable. It's hardly a problem. Well, that's actually even way, way worse. Maybe a hundred times worse for you.
If you sucked on a piece of aluminum, you're getting elemental aluminum, that's bad. You should do that, right?
But if you're kind of healthy gut realistically, you're probably not going to absorb any of that and you're going to deposit it in the toilet.
If you injected it in your arm and it's nano-sized, it's going to, it's going to immediately cross any blood-brain barrier when it circulates through the brain.
And across the blood-brain barrier, anything that gets into the brain, whether it's a toxin or whether it's a biotoxin, an infection, AIDS, pylori, Lyme disease, et cetera, is going to cause this huge inflammatory response.
The whole idea of you want to prevent disease, certainly dementia and any brain-based diseases, Parkinson's issues with autoimmune neurological issues, you have to decrease inflammation.
So, that's a number one. Supplement-wise, what do you use to decrease inflammation generally in the brain and in the rest of the body is the flavonoids.
I do explain that a little bit on that video as well. So go to cuttersclinic.com search for neuro-inflammation, and you'll see that.
The flavonoids are curcumin, whereas vera trout, green tea extract, quercetin, stiggy nettles, et cetera.
So, there's lots of different flavonoids that can be anti-inflammatory, call me down inflammation.
But if you have a source of inflammation that you're constantly exposing your body to, well, you could swim in curcumin and it's going to do you less good.
So you've got to decrease the source of inflammation.
It's funny while I'm talking here. I'm looking out my window at my bird feeder, and there's a raccoon eating all my bird feed right now.
Sorry. All right. Like we have time for one more question.
What is the best treatment for breast cancer, and if one does not want to do chemo? Well, I picked a loaded last question there.
Oh, well, if the person doesn't want to do chemo, you need to research what else you're going to do.
So I am not one that is against doing chemotherapy or standards of care in any form diagnosed with any diagnosis, but you do want to do your research.
One thing I would recommend is sign up for our stop-biting cancer course. So we got a ton of information on our cutter's clinic website.
And for $50, our stop-biting cancer starts reading the cause course, goes basically over my 600 page book with the same title and has tons of videos on different, different portal calls that you can use.
Really contact our clinic. Set up a time to talk to me if you have cancer, or if you have an autoimmune disease, or if you have anything you need to get more care, immediate care for.
That's called a case review. It's a couple hundred dollars to do a case review, and we'll go over your case, and make some clinical decision-making.
I can guide you with some different lab work that you may want to get done to get to that working diagnosis to be able to move forward with a care plan that you feel comfortable with.
With anything with any disease with any diagnosis, you have to feel peace about the decision-making process that you're moving forward with.
I've had patients that felt pressured into doing chemo, they made a decision to do chemo, and they didn't want to, but there was different pressures that make that decision.
I told them, you don't change your attitude. I don't think you're going to get the same benefit off this chemo.
Change your attitude that, hey, maybe God wants you to do the chemo, and this is going to just work great for you.
I tell you, it makes a big difference in your care plan. You have to feel peace about the decision-making process that you want yourself in.
Alright, we're going to call that a class for today. Remember, go to holistichealthhour.com. You'll see recordings of this class and all of our other courses, classes that we've had called holistic health hour.
Also, if you go to videos.cuttersclinic.com, you'll see thousands or so different videos that I've created on just about everything you could possibly think of in there, indexed.
If you go to cuttersclinic.com, we have blog posts with over well over 1,000 blog posts with a bunch of different videos too.
So we're here to educate, we're here to help you, we're here to support you, whatever you need. If you need personal support, you can make an appointment with me too.
But if you just need education, use those websites. On the cuttersclinic website, you can sign up for courses.
And for $50, you can learn everything you want to know and more about cancer, an auto real disease, a detoxification, a live disease, and a bunch of other things.
So as always, we're here for you and we're praying for you. And we ask that you continue to pray for us, because that's how we are able to continue to do what we're doing.
Alright, thanks so much. Bye-bye.